i'm charlie gillespie i'm here with
buzzfeed and i'm here to tell you guys
my first
my first ever job i was selling dresses
and sunglasses and
junk with my uncle my junk they were
great dresses i had a big sales pitch i
was pretty good at what i did i would
sell over sell my uncle be like bringing
them around because i was just like this
little kid being like wow you look
beautiful in that dress and the people
were like wow thank you so much and yeah
we go to like trade shows all across the
maritimes here's my first real job it's
the first time i got a paycheck even
though it was my uncle so it was like
you know cashing with the table first
time i was star struck this is just like
a couple years ago but my whole family
and i went up to go see a john mayer
concert and we didn't get to meet him or
anything but when he came up on stage
and started playing it was like we were
sitting in someone's garage just playing
music i i i just remember being like wow
like that's that's that's like something
i really want to do oh you know what
sydney crosby i was at the san andreas
hockey school down in pei okay he showed
up and he did like this like masked um
he was like i think it was like the
shadow or the phantom or something like
that and we were all in the benches by
this point and then he comes onto the s
and everybody was just like the old
crowd went
you know i mean that he was skating
around he was doing like these tricks on
the ice but we didn't know it was him
but everyone was like that's two girls
like this has got to be sydney crossing
you're all like freaking out i think
that was pretty starstruck first on set
memory with cam
the guy had such an open heart for
everybody around him and i mean i
watched this kid on tv i was hella
jealous because like my eye was like i'm
saying and you know like everyone
usually goes up and asks like like you
know these questions and stuff i'm just
like dude what was that i'm saying like
was he just like a stud and he talked
about how adam sandler would create
these worlds which uh where like he
would do the script but then he would
come back and be like i don't know say
this this might be funny and he was so
cool like he he just told me everything
every little question every stupid
little question that i had the kid had
one of the biggest hearts so nice to
everybody around you can't not leave
with a bit of inspiration from that
everybody
it was like train tracks and we're all
we're each a train track the scene is
the train going on top of us but we all
like we're together you know it's like
all of our like stuff kind of like
intertwined like one person was adding
on to another and we're we're flowing so
easily and so aside the fact that
they're all beautiful people you know
what i mean like dead gorgeous you know
100 you know we actually got to create
in a freaking audition where usually
people are like so in their nerves and
madison never freaking auditioned in her
life was like freaking rock starring it
you know with these three boys coming in
and making all these jokes and stuff and
she was just like picking it up throwing
it back and maddie actually like she was
yeah she was like freaking knocking it
out of the park whenever we throw
something at her and that's like cool
you know it wasn't she wasn't shy she
was one of us and jared was one of us
and owen was one of us and i was one of
us and together we were that train track
i was talking about that's what i really
wanted but didn't get oh break my heart
it was the one that was getting me my
visa coming down to the states it was
like like these boys down in like the
1960s uh los angeles and they were i was
like a big musician back home where i
like did like trombone and tuba and this
kid was a pianist but a jazz pianist you
know and it was like this this adventure
that they went on kind of like a stand
by me it was so cool it's called flocka
four
i'm gonna get to do it but that's okay
because i'll do another jazz adventure
in the 60s one day let's see
am i famous i don't know maybe the fact
that i get a few more likes on instagram
but what the heck is does that mean
anyways you know what i'm saying
everybody feels like like an extension
of the show you know everybody that's
watched julian the phantoms everybody
has their own piece into it so whenever
i meet anybody who's watched the show
there feels like less of a wall you know
oh hino is really really cool i just
moved down to uh down to the beach down
in in venice and absolutely love it i'm
in the water every single day every
single day i'm going swimming and
usually around like sunset right and i
was swimming and and have my pup i gotta
come back out and then this girl comes
running i was like i thought your dog
was australia this is like a little girl
like maybe like 10 or something and i
don't even know now he's my dog you know
i mean she's like can i pet on like i'm
like yeah yeah go for it i forget her
name but let's pretend she was stephanie
she's like oh i'm stephanie i'm like
okay well i'm charlie and then it was
like this realization in her eyes she's
like are you on a netflix show i'm like
yeah
you know like what do you say like and
so she starts screaming at her friends
down and like come here you guys come
and then all these little girls start
running over and it's like like the sun
has set it's dark now and then this one
girl is like what you want she's like
this guy is luke and truly in the
phantoms and then the other girl turns
around and starts crying i love you so
much i love this show and i'm just like
whoa whoa whoa calm down dude you're
fine like thank you so much for watching
the show but you're good you're good my
first my very first little mermaid's
gotta be in there because i mean she was
so cute you know with the red hair and
she could sing you know look at this
stuff isn't it neat and you'll just be
like yeah it's so cool go for it my
first real crush was gabriella dija and
let me tell you she was this girl down
the street for me a little french girl
and we're good friends now
you want the honest answer
it was the first song that i recorded i
was so stressed you guys i was on voice
rest for like two weeks i was not
allowed to talk because i i had sang too
many songs before we started rehearsing
without any like proper training and i
kind of blew up my voice i i just i
wasn't i wasn't prepared and i didn't
like it i was just like guys can we
please redo it like i give you one more
try so we recorded the whole song again
and then i was like okay this is fun
this is good this is i think i think we
hit the moment buzzfeed thank you so
much everybody for watching make sure
you go check runs only in theaters go
check it out other love
you